semaine les attentats du 11-septembre
polémique aux états unis certaines
familles des deux victimes seront plus
indemnisés que d'autres le critère du
revenu et notamment prise en compte sur
place à washington
etienne leenhardt aranda m la mort de
ces milliers de personnes dont les corps
quotidiennement sont retirés des
décombres du world trade center at-elle
un prix et lequel au risque de rendre
des décisions arbitraires les autorités
américaines ont choisi de fixer un cadre
pour indemniser les familles des
victimes du 11-septembre at-il casas a
perdu son mari ce jour là un agent de
change
et elle ne veut pas être mises devant le
fait accompli
je ne sais pas comment estimer le prix
de la vie d'un homme
jamais on m'avait demandé une chose
pareille mais j'aurais préféré que l'on
discute plus plutôt que nous donner une
formule toute faite
la formule mise au point est très
critiquée parce qu'elle calcule
notamment les indemnisations en fonction
du salaire de la victime comprenez que
les proches d'une femme de ménage par
exemple toucherait 15 à 20 fois moins
que la famille d'un banquier ou d'un
chef d'entreprise dit il faut que l'on
donne une chance à ce programme
d'indemnisation
ce sera de toutes façons beaucoup mieux
que des actions en justice
car et c'est bien là le deuxième motif
de controverses si les familles
acceptent finalement l'indemnisation
proposée par le gouvernement elles
devront promettre de ne pas engager de
poursuites contre les compagnies
aériennes par exemple dans un pays où le
moindre petit contentieux de voisinage
peut valoir en justice des centaines de
milliers de dollars d'indemnités
certains pourraient être tentés
d'engager un bras de fer judiciaire dont
l'issue est incertaine ne compensera de
toute façon jamais l'immense douleur
d'avoir perdu un proche